you guys that can create offense on an  extremely high level in their back quote  of McCullum  James answers with a three LeBron James  seven points five rebounds four assists  and his shitty pointer and in double  figures now with ten  Lillard misses the three about a seven  second difference between the clocks  James pulls up for a deep  [Applause]  James another phrase and Chandler's back  on the floor after getting hurt at the  end of the first half he had a huge back  tap in their game last week to beat  Minnesota James picked up by layman with  four to shoot  LeBron drives is fouled  38 for James and a free-throw away from  passing Wilt Chamberlain  [Applause]  move over we'll make room for LeBron  James number five all-time on the NBA  scoring list